foreign
on Friday Senator Rand Paul's Bowling
Green Kentucky office was Ablaze it took
fire Crews hours to extinguish the
Flames from his building and the two
surrounding now at this time we don't
know what caused the fire but given the
many threats to senator Paul over the
years and his team including the
stabbing of a staffer and an assault on
the senator himself nothing's off the
table Kentucky Senator Rand Paul joins
me now Senator
um what have you learned about the fire
as of now
well you know this was a big fire it
consumed about a city block it took I
think 31 firefighters six fire engines
and in order to contain the Blaze the
Hope was to not let the county
courthouse catch on fire the county
courthouse is just across a narrow
Alleyway and is in a historic building
in our community but for buildings that
were contiguous that abut each other all
caught on fire
they haven't told us how the fire
started or what they believe started the
fire yet we've turned over our video
footage we have a lot of video footage
for our own safety of who comes and goes
at all hours in the building to try to
make sure that nothing untoward does
happen so whether or not that footage
will help in the determination of this
there's some other commercial footage
from around there as well but I haven't
heard any results in the investigation
in any indication otherwise
uh Senator I want to turn to these new
emails uh released at the outset of
covet specifically the written exchange
between Christian Anderson and Andrew
rombout from February of 2020. now Dr
Rambo told Anderson that given this Shi
you know what uh show that would happen
if anyone serious accused the Chinese of
even accidental Dental release my
feeling is that we should say that given
there is no evidence of a specifically
engineered virus we cannot possibly
distinguish between Natural Evolution
and Escape so we're content with
ascribing it to natural process Dr
Anderson concurred saying yep I totally
agree with that very reasonable
conclusion although I hate when politics
is injected into science but it's
impossible not to especially given the
circumstances
um Senator uh this was happening at the
same time Christian Anderson had a grant
proposal for eight nine million 8.9
million dollars at NIH which makes this
pretty uh interesting that they were
talking about the proximal origins of
covid
yeah this was never about science this
was about the business of science it was
about the money follow the money Trail
and you see millions of dollars
exchanging hands in the first few months
of 2020 to the people who came out and
said nothing to see here couldn't have
happened in the lab but there's probably
never been a cover-up in the history of
all politics that was so completely
documented that they were lying to us
every one of their private email says oh
my goodness looks like it might have
come from the lab oh my goodness looks
like it was manipulated and this goes on
and on and on even so much is to say the
one lead virologist who's saying it's
all kooky and conspiracies theory to say
it came to the lab he's saying in
private this is no conspiracy theory
this is not a fringe theory in all
likelihood it could have come from the
lab but then in public they print an
article that Anthony fauci commissions
them he basically says you need to get
this written up as soon as possible he
works on them to edit this and when it
is published it says explicitly this
virus is not a laboratory construct
they none of them believed that they
knew with certainty and it wasn't but
they thought it would harm the business
of science it would harm our relations
with China if it became known that this
came from a lab in China Senator this
was because enormous amounts of money
were on the line with the work that we
were doing with this Wuhan lab and all
the grants that these researchers and
virologists get from NIH correct that's
all involved in all this
yeah it involves money but as you'll
recall when Anthony fauci came before my
committee he said absolutely he funded
no gain of function research in China
but we now have an email from him where
he describes the research they're doing
and says you know what we are suspicious
of the lab because we know they are
doing gain of function research he
describes the project but the project he
described is the project he funded so
everything he's been telling us from the
very beginning has been a lie we've
documented that it's a lie and it's a
felony to lie to Congress and so I've
referred him not once but now twice to
the Attorney General of the United
States for prosecution but as you know
this attorney general's the most
partisan attorney general we've ever had
and it's good luck on getting him to do
his job well at least Anthony fauci has
a plum position at Georgetown University
Senator so they take care of their own
it's great to see you because you're it
like it was a little late for you at 10
o'clock so now we see senator Paul it's
great to see you of the new hour I want
to be on all the time at seven o'clock I
love it all right Senator great to see
you thanks for joining us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else